snooker is a game that requires
incredible precision dedication and
finesse to master and I guess that's why
it's loved by so many people around the
world but what I love about it is how
brilliantly it showcases a number of
physics concepts now the trouble is I am
absolutely terrible at snooker so I
can't really show you anything but I do
know a seven times world champion so the
first thing that comes to mind about
snooker is collisions because the name
of the game is to get the cue ball to
hit the target ball in a very specific
way so that it moves into the chosen
pocket when two smokeable is collide the
collision is essentially elastic which
means the kinetic energy of the system
is conserved before and after the impact
similarly the physical property known as
momentum which equals mass times
velocity is also conserved throughout
each collision which means that you can
take all the momentum from the cue ball
and transfer it to the second ball this
stems from Isaac Newton's very famous
third law of motion one of the three
laws which govern a branch of physics
known as classical mechanics so if I was
to bump into this table I would apply a
force to it and it would apply an equal
and opposite force on me however because
our masses are somewhat different the
table barely moves but I'd bounce back
conserving the momentum with smoker
balls however their masses are pretty
much identical so you can clearly see
momentum being transferred from one to
the other so the cool thing about
momentum is that the velocity part of
the equation doesn't just deal with
speed but it also takes into account the
direction of movement
it enables you to make really cool
angled shots like this now if we take a
closer look at how the balls behaved you
can see that the angle between them
after the collision is a perfect right
angle and this is known as the 90-degree
law what's happening here is that a
portion of the cue balls original
momentum is transferred into the Red
Bull in the direction of the line
between the center of the two balls at
the point of impact meanwhile the cue
ball shoots off in a direction
perpendicular to the red ball
the balls and new velocities which is
shown by the arrows add up to the cue
balls original velocity conserving
momentum across the collision so Stephen
how familiar are you with the 90 degree
rule not at all I mean when you talk
about degrees of angles you're talking a
different language basically I see this
shot I see where I want to put the cue
ball for the next shot and I just I just
made a cue ball go there that's as far
as as technical as I get wow that's
probably why I will never be
this book if I just got an intuitively
feel it but that was just the simple
stuff where things get really
interesting is when you start adding
spin to the ball when you hit it because
this adds extra forces that can make for
some very physics defying tricks like
this all right Steven talk me through
this wizardry what are you doing well
with the most important bowl if the
tables of cueball some it breaks -
you've got to be able control this ball
here topspin you Raymond top of the cube
all right backspin obviously with a
little center as long as you want to go
right hand side left hand side and the
difficult thing is Snoopy table is to
actually have pretty agreement that's
that bat right don't ahead roll your cue
if you don't sense you're adding linear
momentum but use it off-center you're
also adding a second force which is a
turning force on this talk to also give
the ball an angular momentum and I know
this this angular momentum needs to be
conserved
- which is why the ball bounces off the
rail at such a bizarre angle
so what's happening here is that
friction is coming into play after the
ball has been hit by Stephens cue the
only force acting is friction between it
and the surface of the table and because
the ball is spinning sideways it's
unable to roll across the table and so
starts sliding across it instead this
creates what is known as kinetic
friction and the direction of that
friction affects where the ball goes as
the ball slows down the rotating
frictional force has a bigger effect
making the balls trajectory curved more
okay so I guess it's not magic tell me
about the sweet spot on the ball what I
would determine is maybe just slightly
above the center where you're playing a
topspin shot but you don't really want
any lag you just want to topspin to take
effect straight away you want to care
the natural momentum of the cue ball
so yes slightly slightly above the
center yeah because there must be a
point on the ball where if you hit it it
makes the ball roll perfect and
interestingly there's actually a
mathematical derivation for insurers
it's nice and simple it looks like this
[Music]
easy peasy if you say so
you guys Steven talk me through this
talking thing because whenever I played
pool that is not what I need
basically sticker players the chocolate
you know the cute after every single
shot you don't need to this is kind of
like a habit so what we're doing we're
gonna even even caught enough chalk on
the tip so when we play shots play with
extremely spent you getting gripped on
the cue ball
so I guess what's happening is when
you're trying to hit these extreme shots
a smaller surface area of the q-tip is
actually making contact with the ball so
it's very important that you have as
much friction as possible to get that
spin yeah absolutely I mean if you can
see if my turn it's kind of rounded so
yet so that the only part of that tip is
actually making contact with the cue
ball so yeah if you're in low and
especially down if you've got no chalk
in there yet that you were just a golf
shot you just check the keyboard okay
thank you so as you can see snooker is a
fantastic way of showcasing some of the
laws that govern our physical universe
it's also a great way to flex your
mathematical muscles with some geometry
unless of course you're Steven Henry to
whom it just comes completely naturally